[Music]
hey everybody i'm so excited about this
episode nft's the state of the union
we've got tons of great guests with us
today episode number 32.
um so please keep the conversation going
hashtag marketing for the now let's go
one other quick thing
you're just here avery we just got you
can bring avery on episode number one we
just heard from gary that he is please
join us
uh unfortunately he is still on a plane
that has yet to land
but we're gonna be okay you're gonna be
interviewing paris hilton i hope that's
okay
big surprise
but first up we've got um so i have
avery echonini president of vayner nft
who is going to kick us off with our
conversations and we have lisa mayer
joining us lisa is many many things she
is an entrepreneur philanthropist and
founder and ceo
of my social canvas and the boss
beauties she's got her kick-ass leather
jacket you're going to have to show us
both the front and the back i have a
feeling lisa
we're so excited to hear more about the
mission that you're on in helping uh
support um young girls and with with all
of the work that you're doing as well as
how the nft drop has impacted that so
over to the two of you
awesome andrea thank you so much for
introducing us and thank you everyone
for tuning in it is my honor to be here
today with lisa lisa in
addition to being an extraordinary
entrepreneur he's a dear friend and just
an amazing person so lisa thank you so
much for joining us
avery thanks for having me i'm so
honored i feel like this is just a
coffee chat almost we're chatting and
catching up so i love it i know i love
it and i think you know it was maybe
six months ago when we were doing this
and the launch before boss beauty's i
think you were sitting in that exact
same position um so you started boss
beauty six months ago so much has
happened since then i would love for you
to tell our listeners a little bit
around the origin story behind boss
beauties and and why you decided to
bring it to life
yeah absolutely um so you know box
beauties is really an extension of the
work that i've been doing for the last
decade um so in the space of nfts i've
been in this space for six months which
feels like a long time even though it's
been less than a year um but i've been
in the space of mentoring and empowering
women for the last 10 years um you know
with my previous work we've mentored
women i've had olympic athletes we've
had ceos um entrepreneurs um women in
the fashion industry sit down and really
mentor women in college in high school
from our community so mentorship and
empowerment is totally my passion
it's my dream job it's what gets me up
every morning um and wakes me up um but
really i found the nft space
about a year ago and was so excited i
actually have to give some credit
to gary
because who hasn't watched some of his
videos looked at some of the content and
been inspired so you know that's part of
what inspired me to get into the space
actually um i have to give him some
credit but you know when i founded boss
beauties with anthony my husband um
it would have been a crazy time to start
a new company or start a
project in the nft space but i knew that
the timing was so right
i knew the timing was perfect um if i
didn't start it then i would probably
never do it i was actually a new mom i
think i told you that avery when we
first got
i had a three-month-old baby
i was in that phase as a mom getting up
three or four four times a night
with my newborn to feed him just
honestly i was operating on very limited
sleep
but that is actually showing how much i
believed
in the nft space and the future of web
3.
so that's a little bit of my story i
mean again not the perfect timing to
start something in the nft space but
i knew the timing was right and i had to
jump in at that time
i think that your timing was incredible
lisa you know one with your dual role as
a caregiver that's particularly
inspiring but also just in terms of the
nft market maturity i think you joined
and you created this community at this
right time when a lot of women were
curious about nfts and i believe for a
lot of your community this might have
been their first ever nft you did
multiple education sessions to bring
them along
totally yeah and you were actually our
first nft education session um we had
people that had never been involved in
the space at all they didn't even they
didn't know what an nft was
and avery i was so grateful that you
jumped on and helped educate our
community so yeah
with yam i remember that was a great
thing i can't believe how recently it
was um but anyway so just as a lot of
your community was new to nfts and we
were teaching them the fundamentals
there are a lot of brand leaders um who
are watching right now we're also
interested in nfts but they have no idea
how
to get involved what would be your
advice for companies who are interested
in this space um but not sure where to
start
yeah you know i've thought a lot about
this so i have three things that i'm
going to share with if you're working at
a brand or maybe you want to jump into
the nft space but you don't know where
to start so here are my three things
number one my advice is to really
immerse yourself
in the community in the nft space before
launching something or really entering
as a brand right um at the end of the
day
business is really about people right
and the nft space is no different so get
to know the space get to know the
community um you know get into the
twitter but it's it goes so much farther
than that i would say is really to get
get to know everyone um and spend time
it's not going to happen overnight i've
seen you know influencers and companies
try to get into the space overnight and
you really need to have some patience
like get in and learn before you launch
a project um and finally my third thing
is be authentic you know be authentic
and intentional
um explore meaningful partnerships right
which i know are you could partner with
vayner nft and some of the brands that
you work with but really explore ways
that you can be
authentic and stay true to your values
as a brand
when you enter the space so those are my
three things and that's my my piece of
advice that's so smart lisa and i know
you also did that before you launched
boss beauties you're a collector you
were integrated with some of the artists
in the space and the community in the
space and that you know i think really
showed as you all went through your
minting process
um so on that note boss beauties has
successfully collaborated with so many
amazing brands and i think you all are
really the gold standard when it comes
to thinking about crafting the right
brand partnerships with nft programs so
i would love to understand um from you a
little bit of how these all came to life
you've done barbie you've done even
marcus hugo boss marvel um these are
some incredible brands how did those
sort of come to life and um yeah tell us
a little bit more about why these
collaborations worked
yeah absolutely um well first of all
we're so honored and excited that we've
had the chance to partner with
incredible brands out there but really
it goes back into my final point as far
as advice to brands um we were really
looking to be intentional and explore
partnerships with brands that aligned
with our values in some way right so as
an example with barbie and i have to say
my five-year-old self
never thought that i would be an
entrepreneur and partner with barbie to
impact women and give back to women so
that was a dream partnership um we
launched an nft together with barbie um
we're exploring a lot of other things um
with them but that i can't quite share
just yet but um when building that
partnership and the others we were
thinking of ways we could make it a win
for barbie as well as boss beauties
right so a poor a hundred percent
actually of the proceeds from our nft
collaboration went back to the barbie
dream gap project which empowers women
and girls to dream big um and then you
know that was something that was a win
for us to be able to partner with them
and and collaborate we also partnered
with hugo boss and we launched some
merchandise um the merchandise actually
sold out um i believe in a day on hugo
boss's website they have to restock some
of it now i wanted to get one and i
couldn't i'm gonna have to get the
secret hookup from the theo
we'll be able to hook you up we can
totally hook you up but yeah i mean i
think with that that was a win for us to
partner together um we're also funding
dream like a boss which is a mentorship
program with support from hugo boss for
women and girls so they'll learn about
the fashion industry and and learn about
business
but we also as i said um drove a lot of
you know marketing for that product
collaboration and and worked with them
on that so i think building very
authentic
collaborations is what we've been able
to do and we're excited to do that in
the future too
that's so amazing lisa what i'm hearing
from you is you what you're looking for
in partners is folks who really share
your values and can help take boss bds
to irl or boss bv's to a more broader
base of consumers and then the value
that boss buddies can play is helping
these more traditional companies merge
into the world of web 3 in a way that
they're going to be warmly welcomed and
doing something that's a force for good
totally you've summed it up so perfectly
i love that avery
i've got one more question um and i feel
like 10 minutes flies by
you often say that boss beauties is a
vehicle to empower young women um can
you share with our watcher our listeners
a little bit more about what you're
doing to reach women empower them and
encourage them to do anything in their
life and in their career i know there's
the brand partnership side but um as a
holder i also see all the communication
you all are putting out um and it seems
like you're doing a lot
totally yeah no this this is actually
what wakes me up every morning and gets
me so excited um is our work so um just
this month we actually awarded we
surprised um 14 students with a ten
thousand dollar scholarship um it's just
the start there's a lot of other
scholarships we'll be awarding soon but
we surprised them for women's history
month with a scholarship um and then we
have a mentorship program where they get
access to
powerhouse women in different industries
like i said from olympic athletes to
ceos women in fashion and tech
one of the women we mentored last year
just landed her dream internship at
facebook
working in computer science um another
woman we've mentored landed her dream
job at disney
anika and she's been a part of our boss
beauty's family for several years um you
know i've attended some of their college
graduations um i mean it's just
something that we're really passionate
about so
whether it be mentorship or scholarships
or just giving them access
to amazing mentors and women role models
like yourself
that's what we're all about and that's
what how we want to change their career
and and support them in their dreams as
well
that's incredible lisa thank you so much
for taking the time to join us today um
i hope you have an incredible day and we
will catch you very soon
thank you for having me i loved it so
much fun thank you and everybody
beauties on twitter and join their
discord is that a little plug i have to
make
a must a must so next up avery we
welcome rachel weiss and she's got a new
incredible title
she is partner of bold corporate venture
fund at l'oreal usa
rachel lives and breathes all things pop
culture beauty and technology and she's
been called a futurist a culture analyst
writer operator community builder and
technologist and she's forging the
vision for and the future for l'oreal
welcome rachel
rachel thank you so much for joining us
i agree with all of those accolades and
then some and i have to say i love your
lipstick necklace very on brand for
l'oreal i think you might be on mute um
but we are so excited that you are
joining us here today thank you for
being here thank you for having me can
you hear me now
perfect perfectly
so rachel i'm going to start off by um
sharing something a little bit fun about
you you are the proud owner of a blonde
crypto punk can you tell our uh audience
a little bit about how you got into nfts
sort of personally and then we'll talk
about your role at l'oreal and all the
amazing things you're doing there well i
started to really get very intrigued i
would say around 2013
what was happening in the world of
cryptocurrency
and just started to study it as an
economy and play i mean i've always as
someone who has been working in
innovation since the you know advent of
the internet i always have elements of
fomo um and i spent a lot of time during
the pandemic i will tell you listening
to clubhouse
um talking with uh
2020. clubhouse 2020 and learning about
nfts and just started having a lot of
fomo and there was actually someone i
will not name names got a call from gary
and said do you know these crypto punks
and he called me and he said you know
about this nft stuff what do you know
about crypto punks i said i don't really
know anything but i'm going to see if i
can get one so that's that's that's it
that is how it happened um
it's a lot of element of fomo and um
spending a lot of off hours studying and
talking with strangers over the internet
doing your own research you were hearing
about it you were listening you were
reading you were talking to your friends
who were also sort of leaders in this
space and you thought okay i'm in for
listeners who and what viewers who might
not be familiar what is a crypto punk
and what's special about the project
i mean i think it was one of the first
early projects i saw that was really
about like owning a piece of it it was
just such a vibrant community of people
yeah who were like early in this space
um i was just very curious about it i
didn't even really know what was special
about it i was really drawn by the
community of people who were just
getting involved which sometimes for me
is enough of it
of a dangling um object for me to want
to try something and see what's out
there
amazing okay rachel so let's pivot and
talk a little bit about your story
congratulations on the new role l'oreal
can you tell us a little bit about what
you're up to and how you got here
yeah i mean i you know i i have worked
at l'oreal for 15 years um really as a
very early digital employee of the
company um at a time when i came to
l'oreal web 2 was was very new to the
business um it was an emerging platform
and really worked to talk about and
educate and grow
how social media could be a part of
growth for for a big beauty company and
you know built early programs with
youtube and snap and pinterest and i
argue that some of the largest beauty
platforms that we take for granted today
beauty is a very fundamental part of
growth of those platforms and being at
l'oreal as the part as you know at the
foundation and beginning of that has
been very exciting you know my new role
is very much about investing and what
the next you know decade and 20 years
looks like which we all know is on this
who's on this podcast is rapidly
changing and to be able to be an
investor in that space um
aside from being an operator is very
exciting for me as we can empower new
economies you know more diverse
entrepreneurs which has always been at
my heart and really educate around what
these new opportunities look like for
the world's largest beauty company
yeah absolutely and rachel it's
incredible you mentioned a lot of the
sort of leaders within the web 2 world
like youtube and snapchat from your
perspective do you see any parallels
between what happened 10 years ago with
web 2 and what's happening today with
web3 well i'm going to age myself
because i was also at the forefront of
web one so
well it's all those amazing you know
beauty products and personal care
products like i you couldn't tell a bit
but but i do feel like
i'm actually feel much more now like i
did when i first started my career in
the 90s about like what's happening here
something revolutionary and radical is
happening and i don't totally understand
it but it's going to change how we
communicate technology is changing it's
changing how we operate and our identity
um on the internet so i think as someone
who's gen x what i love about what's
happening in web 3 it's taking us back
more to that chaotic um
authentic identity where no one knows
really what they're doing or talking
about in a way that's very raw and i
think web 2 evolves so much to be
packaged and to be about putting a
certain image forward and and i find
myself re what i found myself really
excited about what's happening in in
philosophically right now is that it's
kind of going back to that feeling of
we're all on even playing field um and
what happens next
i love that and i remember i actually
was living in san francisco um and i
moved there to work at google in in 2012
and i was feeling like this crazy like
what's happening things are moving so
quickly and
um you know all my friends who were
normal thought i was crazy for doing it
then it became normal and now i'm in
miami in 2022 and it's the same thing
where it feels like this chaotic like
energy and excitement but we're sort of
building the plane as we're flying it so
i echo that sentiment and
i love that i think that's so exciting
it's so exciting and fun um and l'oreal
has also been an early pioneer of sort
of early days in this space so can you
tell us a little bit about how l'oreal
has dipped its you know fingernails um
into the world of nfts
well going back to our conversation we
just said about digital identity and
beauty building some of the largest
platforms you know l'oreal has been a
very early adopter in augmented reality
and if you really think about and
communities and fans right like i don't
think of our brands having you know
communities as communities as consumers
they're fans we have fans of our brands
and fans of our advocacy
and i really think about i thought about
like what does it look like for us to
start to dip our toes in you know over a
course during the days on clubhouse i
met lady phoenix who is a very early um
advocate for talking about what the
economy around um nfts can be
we work together to sponsor with our
brand next cosmetics um the metagala and
in combination with um
mimi choi and rebecca minkoff we've
created a very unique um ar filter that
you could wear to the gala and you would
have as a token for participating so it
was a really early space around the
concept that augmented reality meets
nfts meets digital expression could be
something that could really be the
future of what beauty what would a value
and beauty could be for in the nft web 3
space i love that and i i also love that
l'oreal has done an incredible job of
galvanizing your brand fans and your
communities and bringing along others
like into this space as well you just
talked about the partnership with
metagala and with rebecca minkoff what
your company did with reds of worth and
a number of nft native artists another
extension of that that really brings
more people in and this sort of sense of
inclusivity that i think is core to how
l'oreal communicates
yeah i think yeah no absolutely
so all right you all know what you're
doing we've got rachel at the helm now
helping shape this bold ventures what
would be your advice and your guidance
um to some of the the brands who are
looking to get involved with this nft
space what it what's the you know rachel
white's take on what they should do well
i think one thing i've learned along the
way and along with my partners and and
and
in the company is that
it's think beyond just a campaign really
learn the infrastructure of how this
works we took a step back after that
first campaign to really think about
what does secondary markets look like
how do we build this like there's a lot
it's not just a drop and campaign there
is infrastructure attached to it and
learning about that and educating your
organization is extremely important the
second thing is you know think about
what's next if you are going to get your
toes dip and you're getting all this
excitement and your pr headline your
community wants to know like all right
now what you know i think the difference
between web 2 and web 3 is that people
really want to participate in your brand
and your story an ongoing way versus
just a one-off what's a one-off drop
right and don't disappear um you know
those are really my my three learnings
that i've learned this year don't and
don't think of your
humans who participate as consumers
really think about them as your fans
i love that don't ghost think about them
as your fans i think that's such good
advice i know i got into the space
because i'm a fan i'm a fan of brands
i'm a fan of beauty i'm a fan of
technology i'm a fan of startups right
like you know and i've always my success
i attribute is to the community around
me who cared about the same things and
it's been hard but now like the
infrastructure that that community you
can really you can connect with all
kinds of people and i think that's super
super exciting
yeah rachel i also just want to commend
you like one of the leading female
executives who's a proud owner of some
of the you know best nfts and best parts
of collection so i think it's really
inspirational how you are personally in
the community yourself and that puts you
in such a great place to advise and
guide you know others in your company
and some of your investments so thank
you so much for joining us today very
much appreciate it and we will catch you
very shortly thank you so much for
having me it's great to see you
thank you rachel
next up we welcome the team from bear
paint company we've got jody allen who's
the global cmo and andy lopez the vp of
brand marketing they have made quite the
team as they made their first nft drop
at south by southwest welcome jody and
andy thank you thank you
excited to be here
awesome jody and andy thank you all so
much for taking the time to join us um i
love the backgrounds and the colors
behind it um
you know you all have been incredible
partners very recently with vayner on
doing your first activation um into the
world of web 3. um you made your first
dive into the nft space at south by
southwest partnering with the doodles
project
so i would love to understand and share
a little bit more with our audience on
how this all came to life
great well i'll take that one um so
thank you avery we're really excited to
be here and you know as i think about
the partnership
uh color really has always been very
integral to the bear brand and so you
know as we really thought through this
we were really looking for a partner in
the metaverse who is just as colorful
as we feel we are and we're really
looking for a partner that would be a
perfect match for our brand and you know
as we explored with you and the teams
you know we had such i felt like a
unique and creative opportunity
where bear was able to come in and help
doodles create this real-life experience
at south by southwest and then doodles
really did an amazing job of introducing
bear to a new innovative colorful a very
fun community
that i would say we probably hadn't been
fully reaching before and um you know we
really felt like this partnership
was super authentic and uh we're really
excited about uh how everything really
worked out so far
amazing it was a match made in color
heaven so
let's go back in time a little bit um i
think we started talking about this in
december when the doodles project had
very recently launched i want to hear
your honest take when we were first like
yes fair executives you should do a
partnership with the doodles what was
your honest take on the project
yeah um you know i i think we actually
heard from doodles from from you guys
you know working with you guys coming up
with some um exciting innovation we came
to you we said hey we want to kind of
get in the space but you know i think
what the theme of this has been really
that authenticity um and i think when we
heard about doodles i mean our first
instinct was hey let's kind of look up
this brand a little bit more we at that
point um which is hard to believe just a
few months ago we were still in that
early phase of trying to understand how
brands played a role in the nft world so
you know after you mentioned about
doodles and we looked them up and we saw
again that colorful palette that they
had and just those iconic colors it just
felt natural uh like a natural
partnership that we just had to be a
part of and after learning about you
know their story specifically around the
founders after learning a little bit
more about their community
just learning about the impact that
they've made in the nft space um you
know in the important role that color
played we were super excited about it
and and i think we just wanted to figure
out and we were super eager as you know
you know avery helped us through those
these last couple months to just get
started and make something happen with
them as soon as possible and then it
really you know authentic and big way
amazing and andy for the folks who are
not familiar with exactly what we did at
south by um yeah our now iconic paint
can maybe um you can tell us a little
bit about like why the partnership was a
perfect fit for bear and then also how
it actually came to life um at south by
which is in many ways like the center of
creativity and culture making um for
this progressive new community yeah
exactly um and you know as jody
mentioned at the beginning it's really
all around this idea of color you know
color is the best way for our brand to
really inspire and motivate and truly
show like what that transformation is uh
for our products and what they can do
and so when you combine that you know
with leveraging those doodles iconic
colors it creates such an authentic
partnership and the only you know it
felt so natural to be able to launch
that in real life and and you know bring
their uh world into uh south by
southwest um and at south by southwest
where we have these innovators and these
creators of these entrepreneurs
and you know i think
to be able to immerse yourself into that
palette and really you know gain that
experience and understand the different
colors i mean it was so fun to pick
their colors that match so closely with
the doodles palette so that you know
people can go out and buy those colors
and paint their rooms and really live
and breathe on the doodle experience uh
every single day because that community
is so special um so that was fun to be
able to kind of immerse yourself into
into that and then you know as we
mentioned we have the uh the paint cans
which was a nice experience where you
could um there's a poep on it where you
could scan it and you know it's kind of
our first entry into that space as well
uh which was super exciting and then you
know another nice little touch was we
had colorful m ms that matched the
colors of the doodle so again it's it's
an authentic way to do it but still a
surprising delight for the consumers
that were attending the event and then
just as exciting for people that were
following you know on the social space
and be available to um see it and kind
of lift through it virtually as well
that is so tremendous i think there were
many instagramable moments and one of my
favorites was part of the bear um
activation at the doodles
uh event was this spray paint can that
said bear on it you could basically like
you know virtually spray paint this
digital wall and it was really fun and
cool especially as you guys play with it
and actually people played with it who
is the you know most valuable living nft
artist which was pretty cool and i saw
that post go viral on twitter so it's
nice to to see the community really
engaging and loving the experience um
that was so so carefully designed and
just to like the earlier points of lisa
who's a creator in this space i think it
felt so authentic and natural and and
that's what really made it work um
so you know jody i'd love to ask you in
in what ways did this sort of initial
foray allow you all to connect with the
nft community and and were you expecting
this kind of a response like you're a
cmo and a paint this you know world is
is
very fast ever changing so i'd love to
hear from you on this
absolutely i would say it definitely
exceeded our expectations um you know as
you mentioned you know we really started
working together on this back in
december and i i feel like
you know together what we were able to
accomplish and then just to see the
reaction
of the nft community and this
partnership in real time was was amazing
and
um super engagement and you know i
what i really felt like was
there was a great connection of our
brand to the community
and then you know as i looked at kind of
the momentum that was building
really leading up as well as during the
south by southwest activation
and then after um i would say you know
we've seen incredible at really
incredible engagement um throughout so
it was interesting because i you know as
i learned more about doodles throughout
this entire process you know i really
you know doodles obviously has a really
large footprint and an ft community with
a lot of really positive following
um but they really did a great job of
helping kind of bridge us um into that
community in such a unique and fun way
um like i said with with the engagement
that uh more than we could have ever
expected
amazing andy i know we've got just one
minute left here so maybe give us a
little alpha give us a little tease
where do you think this partnership with
doodles could go in the future yeah you
know i'll just say you know when it
comes to color the possibilities are
really endless um i think we're all just
finding a new and innovative innovative
ways to really bridge that in real life
experience with the metaverse
so you know i would say south by
southwest was just you know laying the
foundation of an ongoing partnership
between barren doodles and really
excited to work with them and see what
more we can do together
amazing i love it well thank you both so
much for taking the time to join us um
appreciate it and look forward to
hearing more about what's next with bear
and nft space
awesome thank you for having me team
love that background
all right next up we welcome pepsi's cmo
todd kaplan
todd oversees all marketing for the
pepsi brand at pepsico north america he
has taken an unapologetic and culture
forward approach as he has re-energized
the pepsi brand delivering its first
positive sales growth in
more than 10 plus years
um including 15 consecutive quarters of
positive sales growth and increased
brand equity across the board
gary asked me to apologize todd that he
wasn't able to join and lead this
conversation today but he's stuck on a
plane but miss avery is gonna lead the
way oh good i love avery and i love gary
as well but uh all good how's it going
avery good todd thank you so much for
making the time in your schedule to join
us um i know our viewers want to hear
from the king of pepsi on all the
amazing things that you all have cooking
um your track record speaks for itself
and all the cool stuff that you've done
all the culture forward moments and i
think the world is still buzzing
recovering from the halftime show
but for today let's focus on nfts so
todd um pepsi launched one of the most
um successful nft programs to date from
any brand um with pepsi mic drop program
can you tell us a little bit about how
this side this sort of nft journey began
and a little bit of the inspiration
behind the mic drop
yeah sure we knew we uh
um you know to get into the space since
it's been kind of uh you know developing
at a very early stage and we know we
wanted to get in uh in a way that was
authentic to the pepsi brand and pepsi
has always been this brand that's
steeped in music and culture uh like you
said with the pep super halftime show
all the way back to michael jackson
britney spears you know beyonce music is
such a deep part of its heritage and we
thought the mic drop is just such a fun
way tapping into the whole generative
art kind of trend that's you know there
in nfts but doing it in a way that's
very pepsi you know there's only uh 1
893 of them which is the year that pepsi
was born 1893. uh we gave them out for
free uh to consumers so we didn't want
to
charge a minting fee or we you know and
all consumers have actually through
secondary sales uh made over 10 million
dollars in secondary sales that's 100
gone to the consumers for it uh we've
offset the carbon you know footprint and
in making them and just doing it in our
own way and uh you know they've been
wildly successful i think one even sold
for a hundred thousand dollars we saw
the other day so it's been it's been
moving so uh we're feeling great
the market is the market as uh as we
like to say and the market is hot for
pepsi mic drops so todd um i think that
pepsi's connection to music is so um
it's so ubiquitous and you all have done
so much cool stuff with music are there
any famous collectors of the mic drop
that we might want to share with the
broader community
yeah there's there's a bunch of you know
i know snoop's got a mic drop i think he
tweeted his during like right after the
super bowl halftime show and viral if
i'm not wrong i think he dropped the mic
after he dropped the mic go figure um
you know liam payne uh there's a number
of people you know uh that are you know
continuing to get this and i think just
as you look at our role in music and
culture the pepsi's always had a rich
connection you know to kind of a lot of
these these musicians and and whatnot
and we have a a really great road map
built you know for the mic drop and a
very ambitious and bold plan around it i
think right now what you're seeing is
we're just really pacing ourselves as uh
and we can talk about this too is a lot
of big companies you know we have to
kind of make sure we're bringing the
rest of our organizations along as you
think about our legal teams finance a
lot of other implications as we uh
continue to get deeper into space we
want to also make sure we're doing it
responsibly and for the long haul so we
don't get the rug pulled
absolutely i think that's that's so
smart taught and maybe for uh other
brands who are listening what is some of
you know you work for a huge company um
how are you able to galvanize all of the
appropriate folks across pepsico um to
align on the strategic approach to pull
this off and like you said do so in in a
pretty differentiated way and then it
was a free mint that was had incredible
demand obviously i was part of it and i
remember the
site was like crashing and like it's it
was under like a second when you know
893 people had registered and um you're
just a really a testament to the amount
of demands so how are you able to get
everybody aligned and what would be your
guidance for any other brands who are
looking to explore this yeah it's it's
tricky and this reminds me i know the
big parallel everyone says is remember
when web 2 happened and some of you
don't uh i unfortunately do as a as an
old man here right now that i am but the
um but listen it is a lot of just the
education you know it's different when
one thing like when ticktop pops up out
of thin air one year and everyone's like
oh how does it work
there's general principles of web 2 that
are understood so it's just a different
execution of some of the same things you
know connectivity video all of that as
you look at web 3 the whole
infrastructure is different you know the
digital contracts nfts what is the
metaverse how does all this stuff work
and so uh cryptocurrency is very scary
from finance people so as you look at
all these things from a company's lens
there's a lot of education involved as
you think of a lot of teams and frankly
because it's so new much like when web 2
started you're even seeing it continue
to get regulated in the web 2 around
privacy and all that web 3 as it relates
to securities as it relates to money
laundering there's all these kind of
things that could be watchouts as you
think about nfts in the world of nfts
big companies need to be responsible in
taking the right steps and so we're
doing a lot of education you know i'm
doing a lot of internal discussions and
trainings and immersions and and all of
that to really get everybody on the same
page with what we're trying to do so
that as we move forward and again we
have big bold plans to do really great
stuff in the space moving forward not
just on pepsi but i would imagine across
a number of our brands uh we want to
make sure we're uh we're taking the
right steps and setting up something for
the long haul
awesome and todd i think one of the
reasons that you really have that
long-term vision to build this road map
and build this multi-year plan for the
mic drops and and you know subsequent
ways you can include your fans in this
experience and and really tap into the
future of fandom is that you yourself
are an nft collector how did you sort of
get into this space and you know any
tips and tricks of how you've educated
yourself because i think you really
being that that practitioner yourself
gives you a really clear vision around
what's appealing totally you know listen
a lot of people in my seat or in a lot
of other companies you know i would say
may not want to get get their hands
dirty or might just say hey send me a
white paper an email or let me read a
couple articles like
this space does not work that way you
got to get in it you got to get dirty
you got to get scammed on discord you
got to get your crypto stuff going you
got there's so many layers and you know
and i've said this before right now
um the nft experience for consumers as a
marketer it pains me because it is a
horrible consumer journey you know you
got to give all this personal
information to get your digital wallet
you got to then buy your ethereum then
you you know and figure out that on
coinbase or wherever you're going then
you got to figure out your nft which
project you know how are you going to do
it you know you got to pay gas you got
to then go into the discord like it's
very layered and i equate it a lot to um
you know when the internet was just
starting and web 2 was just starting you
know the experience wasn't what it was
today remember web pages used to load
like bit by bit
right and the the concept of the
internet was not matching the execution
of the internet back then similarly when
video started you know streaming
bandwidth all the stuff you're seeing
right now with you know netflix and real
time streaming you know zoom would not
be possible when web 2 first started
right so
infrastructure has to catch up you know
other apps developers and companies are
going to be the big things in this space
that we've never even heard of haven't
been invented yet today and there are
going to be known entities that are
we're going to be like oh yeah remember
them like the the blockbuster kind of
type stuff as well and so it is at that
point where it's early which is great to
kind of immerse yourself kind of feel
the vibe of the space get involved with
some projects you know try some stuff
and uh that's basically what i've been
focusing on doing uh while we're kind of
building this as a brand and our
strategy knowing hey the rules are gonna
change 50 times in the next handful of
years as we march towards this you know
eventual metaverse years and years down
the road uh that's that's kind of how
we're approaching it i love it you're
thinking about really that long game and
i mean pepsi has been around for
centuries so it's hardly a a web 2 brand
right we've got a long road ahead and
sort of building um the future of
pepsi's uh experiences in the
meadowverse so
a little bit about what's coming next um
and some of the cool stuff that you
might have planned any irl
tie-ins potentially coming in the future
yeah well well i can't tell you the full
you know you know thing that we got
planned obviously but we do have a lot
of really exciting things planned as we
think about the pepsi mic drop for the
long term as we think about building our
road map even in terms of our web3
strategy is around the pepsi brand you
know um it's a really interesting
thought as a marketer to think about you
know how do you take a brand or a
business that is
so
irl right this is a product you put
inside your body you drink it it's
something and when you think of like how
does that work if people are going to be
spending all this time in a virtual
world right and what are the things
beyond kind of the cola but as you think
about the brand and our role in music
and you think about our role in culture
and a lot of other things and so it's a
really fun process to think about and as
we're starting to dream up and look at
potential partnerships look at other
ways in look at ways to kind of build
you know from real life to the metaverse
to
you know everything in between broadcast
and how all these kind of areas really
connect together um i just think it's an
exciting time and um you know i'm
excited to hopefully share a lot more as
we uh continue on the journey
incredible todd thank you so much for
taking the time everyone follow along
pepsi on twitter needs no further
introduction appreciate you
all right
all right next up we welcome the paris
hilton she is chairwoman and ceo of 111
media paris is a pioneer in tv
podcasting and nfts and an innovator in
building businesses social media and
celebrity branding since starring in the
simple life paris has built a global
empire as a businesswoman she's also an
influencer activist dj designer investor
recording artist philanthropist
host
actress chef model and author we're so
excited to have you today paris and uh
deep apologies from gary who's stuck on
a plane and wants to have a follow-up
conversation later on
thank you amazing to be here
paris thank you so much for joining us
and i'll first start off by saying that
i'm a huge admirer of your work and your
trailblazing all over i'm in different
industries but particularly in web 3 and
a lot of times people ask me which
celebrities get it and paris hilton is
always my first response so i'm super
honored to be here with you today
thank you so much to me
all right so from starting your own
media company to launching your own nft
collection you seem to always be ahead
of what's next um in culture and in
technology so can you share with us a
little bit about how you became
interested in all things web 3 and how
your journey got you here
well i've always been an undercover nerd
and i've always been obsessed with
technology
and um i got involved into the crypto
space back in 2016 when i had dinner
with the founders of ethereum
and i just
just having this dinner i was just so
fascinated by what they were talking
about and
you know it was also new to me i
obviously didn't know all the
technicalities of it but i knew i wanted
to learn more i knew this was the future
and then getting involved into the nft
space that was back in 2019 when i was
approached to do my first nft for
charity and this was benefiting the
fires in australia
and um ever since then i've just been
just going more and more into the space
and i'm loving it investing into it and
building in my metaverse and it's just
been
just the best time of my life
and it's just getting started so you
said you started investing in crypto in
2016 so pretty early on vitalik is a
legend for anyone who um is not familiar
with him check him out uh his you know
content is one incredibly inspirational
and two incredibly entertaining and
three incredibly educational
so paris you know you've invested in a
lot of crypto startups as well um can
you tell us a little bit more about that
and what you look for when you're
investing in some of these startups
i really look into founders who have a
vision people that i really believe in
people who i think are good kind people
who want to give back to the community
and are doing things that are innovative
and interesting and
that's why i was really drawn to origin
protocol right from the beginning i was
going on clubhouse basically every
single night during the pandemic and
just meeting so many different people in
the community and i started talking with
them with josh and matt and i was just
blown away by what they were doing and
i invested into them and i am their
chief inspiration officer as well
so i just i love people who really want
to give back to the creator i think
that's so important and also investing
into genies because i love avatars i
love the metaverse
and so many other different projects so
it's just i really yeah i just want to
really work with people that i believe
are trying to bring good to the space
because unfortunately in these spaces
there are certain people that come in
and they're being greedy and they're
only thinking of themselves and
i don't want to be associated with those
type of people i want to really just be
a part of things and share my platform
and my voice with those that are doing
good for the world
that's so inspiring so everybody check
out genies and origin protocol
and paris you also have your you know
most recent nft collection paris past
lives new beginnings in collaboration
with super plastic i'd love to learn a
little bit more about how this
collection came to be and also the
symbolic meaning behind it
well past lives new beginnings is
symbolic of just my past two decades in
the media and
especially in the early 2000s when
myself and many others were just really
treated unfairly and i feel like i was
always underestimated
and now i've really taken back my power
and going to washington dc and becoming
an advocate and fighting for change to
stop the abuse of children
and i really believe by telling my story
and what i went through that you know
the truth will set you free and
those were just symbols of those pieces
and then i also did my polygon piece
which i set the price point at 11.11
cents because i wanted it to be
accessible to
others and to my fans and when we did
the research after we saw that 65
of the buyers of the 25 000 of those
had never had a wallet before this was
their first nft
so it was just really exciting to bring
new people into the space and now my
next drop is with the legend pack which
i'm so excited for ash metamorphosis 2
and
that drop is happening on march 28th and
i'm just so proud to be a part of it so
many incredibly talented artists and
it's just very exciting
i love that accessible price point
because i think for many new to nft
consumers or crypto curious folks it can
be a little intimidating to be paying
you know an ether mint or something so
it's
you know generous and also so strategic
to do something that brings in more of
your community and have that be their
first nft and first introduction into
web three so where can we check out your
next drop where will it be dropping
um that will be if they go onto pax
twitter they can go onto the link there
and um everything is up there but march
28th is the drop amazing follow pack and
of course paris
stay tuned for march 28th okay so you
also are in the metaverse paris and you
have created paris world on roblox
um would love to learn a little bit more
about your virtual
world your future the metaverse and the
epic new year's eve virtual party that
you have at the platform
well i've been obsessed with the
metaverse even before there was a name
with it for it um back in 2018
i released my documentary the american
meme where i was already getting myself
mapped out into an avatar because i had
thought of this whole world called paris
world where people could come and they
can hang out with each other and they
could just be what any avatar they want
to be
and they could watch me dj and it could
just be this kind of virtual place where
people could go hang out
um but the technology wasn't available
that many years ago so now to see it
coming to life is so exciting
and uh with dash radio i developed paris
world inside of roblox and we did the
first ever new year's eve party and we
had twice as many people there as in new
york times square on new year's eve so
that was just amazing and we also just
did the first fashion week in the
metaverse because new york fashion week
was happening and i was like let's just
bring that to paris world too
because i really want to bring as many
in real life things to the metaverse as
well because not everybody gets to
experience certain types of experiences
so
i really love just bringing my world
into the metaverse and um now i was just
at south by southwest um for sandbox and
i dj'd their event there and now we are
going to be building a paris world
inside of there
so um yeah i just feel like with web 3
the possibilities are truly endless and
it's so much fun that we're able to
create these amazing worlds and
experiences and art and it's just
it's just such what i'm about so um
yes
yeah the south by one was the talk of
the town in austin um and it's amazing
to see paris world now coming to sandbox
as well
um and what you've done in central land
in roblox so many amazing places paris
world takes over the metaverse so paris
what is next for you on any front
whether it's nfts or the metaverse or
something beyond
i'm just going to continue investing
into the space
also empowering female artists
especially
lifting other artists up sharing my
platform
also digital wearables um
designing a fashion brand for the
metaverse right now
and just collaborating with artists that
i really love and
um just there's there's so much
happening it's just and oh yeah the one
thing i'm very excited about which i
just did this weekend
is i'm doing a whole like crypto web 3
based ep for my next album
and i have my first song and it's called
to the moon with like mike and dimitri
vegas
and it's a crypto based nft like we talk
about basically everything the metaverse
crypto nfts all of that in the song
and i'm really excited for everyone to
hear the song and also see the music
video
and perform it at tomorrowland the
biggest music festival in the world this
summer
to the moon is the perfect ending for
this parent thank you so much for your
time um yeah
for all of your work leading the way
into space thank you it's my honor and
pleasure i love this space i love the
community and tell gary i said what up i
love him so inspired by him i'm
listening to all of his podcasts he's
just so brilliant and
yeah so happy to be on here and you guys
have an awesome team
thanks paris
fantastic thank you paris
next we welcome alexandra
ford english she is the global brand
merchandising director at ford motor
company alexander was elected to be to
the board of directors at ford last year
and is responsible for driving growth
through an expanded collection of
lifestyle merchandise previously
alexandra led markets and operations for
ford's autonomous vehicle welcome
alexandra
thank you i'm thrilled to be here
alexandra thank you so much for making
the time you are you know such an
amazing person and you've done such
incredible work with ford we're grateful
to have you on this show
um so thank you for being here with us
this afternoon
thank you for having me i'm thrilled to
be here
amazing so alexandra i would love to
hear your perspective on you know you've
got a very deep and entrenched
relationship with ford i'd love for you
to tell our audience a little bit about
yourself and a little bit about how you
are building the ford fan base in new
ways into the future
great
um yes i do have a quite the background
of ford motor company um i've been with
the company in my personal life since
day one but professionally joined the
company a couple of years ago
and we've been in a variety of spaces
within the company all of which i
consider sort of the new so autonomous
vehicles mobility
the software and the vehicles
and i recently moved over into our
merchandising and licensing space which
i actually was working in the retail
industry prior to joining forward and
thought i had left those days behind me
sort of sadly and it's all coming full
circle so traditionally we've had a
sort of core licensing business but
what's really exciting about what we're
doing now is using merchandising and
licensing to
attract new customers to our brand and
then also engage our existing customers
in different ways and so
one of the things we're thinking about
and expanding our portfolio
is web3 and how can we engage
customers in
different areas in different
products but what i'm most excited about
is
traditionally our company is a product
company and and that's great but with
nfts and the metaverse and web3 we're
able to layer in
digital products experiences and really
engage those customers in new ways
and add new value to our customers um
and then attract people who frankly
probably have never really looked at
ford and might buy a vehicle of ours it
might not and that's okay too so
um really the possibilities seem quite
endless in this space
amazing and alexandra ford's another one
of those sort of leading american
institutions icons how has it been
navigating the world of web 3 for a
company like yours knowing that in a lot
of ways actually like henry ford was
like the technical pioneer um who really
like changed the game for american
innovation in so many ways and you know
now generations later here we are doing
it again how is it navigating the world
of web 3 for for a huge company like
ford
well entering the space in an authentic
way is very important to us and you know
that avery so we're actually working
with vayner nft to think about how we
enter in a authentic but also very
sustainable way so this is more than
sort of a marketing headline approach
for us we believe there's there's real
value here
and you mentioned the evolution of the
vehicle
there's so much software in our vehicle
and increasingly so
and that's only going to go up and up so
the utility of the vehicle is
increasingly going to be in the software
and
less than the hardware although that
will still be important
therefore there's so much we can do in
the web3 space but it's
right now we're balancing the moving
fast with actually building something
sustainable which is always attention we
don't want to get left behind or caught
on our back foot
but at the same time there's no
i would say
very clear path or obvious partners
throughout the value chain and the tech
stack and so we're really evaluating
that in real time
making sure that we have the best
customer experience
and
figuring out
how we need to build our um internal and
external presence to really support that
yeah absolutely and you know alexander
i've been very impressed with how
thoughtful how strategic you are and how
sustainability-minded ford is um as an
as an institution really thinking about
sustainability not just in the sort of
emissions of nfts but really in
sustainability of the program how can
you all design something that enables
ford loyalists and ford fans and ford
communities to interact with you all in
this way
um so how are you uh starting to think
about like including some of the other
more traditional aspects in concert with
web3 is there a way we could ever think
about you know a digital collectible
version of a ford or maybe even a
metaverse ford um you know sort of
building off of what paris hilton just
mentioned in paris world could we drive
my virtual forward um in a virtual
metaverse sometime in the next few
decades in the next few years
definitely i think all that's on the
table and that's what's so exciting
the the customer bar for what they
expect out of their products is really
high and i think that
it's going to become much more accepted
and normal and candidly demanded from
our customers that i buy this car in
real life or i'm simply an enthusiast
this car in real life and i want to
either own it or participate in it in my
digital life as well those lines are
getting really blurred and we need to be
able to adapt to our customer um
so i i can't really reveal anything
today that will be coming soon i promise
coming soon yes soon i promise
awesome and you know you mentioned
licensing um at the top of this call and
you know people ford has a huge
licensing business for hats t-shirts
whatever um and i've even seen people
sort of like engage forward in the
metaverse and ask when you all are
jumping into this so i know the
community is excited and because i think
a lot of that self-expression is now
manifesting in the world of web 3 as
well people want to collect things from
brands that they love from celebrities
they love from music that they love and
kind of associate that with themselves
so um how are you able um to build a
culture that balances the iconic at ford
um while leaning into the future like
how do you strike that right balance
from just a personal perspective
yeah that's always a tension and you you
see us do it a little bit in our our
vehicle product line so we electrified
the f-150 so we have our lightning
coming out
so how can we
stay true to our core vehicles and our
core customer but then also attract that
really tech forward customer and so i
think at the beginning at least
my my personal hypothesis is that's
going to be the type of customer who's
interested in our nft presence our web 3
presence the metaverse
and so maybe at the beginning it's more
about our
software and tech future vehicles but i
do believe there's this nostalgia for
some of our more historical nameplates
and and our collectible cars if you will
come on mustang i mean all the variants
of that we have some um
we have a lot of brand love when it
comes to those iconic vehicles
and there's going there already is
demand for owning those in the digital
space we need to figure out how to do
that in a way that
preserves the value not just for the
company which of course is important but
preserves the value for that customer
because one of the reasons they're so
beloved in the physical space is
there's a finite number of them people
have restored them hands-on there's that
very tangible tactical elements and so
how do you
not just flood the web 3 space with a
lot of board stuff um we've actually one
of the things
that's been most surprising to me since
going on this this down this venture has
been
the level of interest internally at ford
for nfts and web 3 in the metaverse
on the one hand it's been great because
we've been able to move really quickly
on the other hand
like you were mentioning we can't just
flood the space with everything for it
because
it dilutes it for our customer and we
want to create a very clear point of
view but
we will be
satisfying the new tech and then also
doing some old nostalgia as well
alexander that's so so inspirational and
i also have to echo that i've just been
incredibly impressed with how forward
thinking ford is how educated internally
your teams are and how they're leaned in
to um to exploring being thoughtful
strategic as as ford starts to make its
first forays into the space which will
be announced soon so one sort of final
question for you um more broadly than
just ford how do you think some of the
world the work that's happening in the
web3 space might redefine sort of
customer experience and interactions
with brands over time
it's a great question
one of the things will be just the level
of accessibility
so
we'll be thinking much more on a global
scale or global company but i think it's
going to be just table stakes that you
think globally
and that also you have a much more
direct conversation with your customer
and are able to offer this
experiential component as well so gone
are the days when you just put a product
out there
hope somebody buys it and your
the company's job is over
it's going to be a much more
frequent ongoing and reoccurring
conversation and interaction with the
customer which will be great for the
customer because that's a much more
compelling offer it'll be great for the
companies as well
to have that much hands-on interaction
with the customer i mean today companies
can only dream of such things as you're
putting products out there sort of one
by one so
i think if anything it's just gonna up
the ante for what's expected out of
product more generally
i think that's so smart so increasing
globalization and really that iterative
feedback loop that just becomes always
on particularly as we scale out
accessibility and i think you made a
really smart point around scarcity
that's super important when you consider
nft programs because when you look at
the most successful programs to date
we've talked about some of them on this
show whether it's boss beauties or v
friends or pepsi mic drop or crypto
punks they're actually a small number
and that scarcity drives value and it
drives desirability so it's amazing to
hear you echo that same point so
alexandra thank you so much for tuning
in everyone stay tuned to ford's moves
in this space and thank you alexandra
thank you very much
thanks to you both and thanks avery
we love you
next up
we welcome
vayner media's chief innovation officer
eric jacobs who will interview our next
few guests
and a big welcome to sean morrison
artist curator and community builder
in 2021 sean founded the block chain as
a way to amplify the work of women bypac
and lgbtq artists and collectors in nfts
sean is currently head of community at
the palm nft studio an ecosystem built
on culture and creativity welcome eric
and sean
thanks so much andrea and welcome sean
it's it's great to have you on
making
you're great
cool
um one of the things about your
background you are just incredibly
multi-talented you're an entrepreneur
you're an author you're an investor
you're a producer you're an artist so
maybe you can start by telling us a
little bit about yourself and how you
first got into the web 3 space
yeah i i like to say that i'm an
entrepreneur at heart um
you mentioned some of the things that i
do entrepreneur investor author but i do
believe that
community building has been the common
thread for everything that i've done so
even if you consider the three companies
that i started i started a software
development company that's literally
called collective mobile so the idea of
working collectively i also started a
co-working space in in atlanta which is
one of the first co-working spaces uh
focused on the underrepresented uh
community so this idea of community
building has always been central to who
i am and what i do um i came to web3 in
a sort of a very circuitous way um i
think that uh i should at this moment
give a a hack tip to all of the folks
who really tried to explain bitcoin to
me a few years ago and i just simply did
not get it and it was you know the
confluence of those things uh the
pandemic and and everything that really
happened last year that really
made it click for me um and it clicked
for me with nfts because i'm i'm also a
creative as well so the notion of uh
provenance and sovereignty for the
artists really really resonated with me
um and so that that is how i got here
and it's been a wonderful wonderful ride
i have to say yeah it's incredibly
exciting that the space is still so new
and we're all figuring out together what
everything is going to look like
so you mentioned that community is a
thread that runs through all of your
history and as head of community at palm
nft maybe you can tell us a little bit
more about what palm is and what
community means there
yeah um so palm is relatively new we are
a technology company and i like to say
that we exist at the intersection of art
and entertainment um i think as was
touched on in the intro we are building
an ecosystem for culture and creativity
um and when they reached out to me that
those two things really excited me right
uh because that that's sort of part and
parcel of where i come from um but what
also excites me about what we're doing
at palm is the notion that we can along
with our partners on board the next
million you talked about us being really
really early in the space and so um
those of us who have been in this space
for a year are considered like og's but
there are so many other people moving
into the space uh every day um and i
think that palm the palm and ft studio
along with our partners will will
definitely be instrumental in onboarding
uh the next the next million um
when i think about community in that
respect um what's important to me is
making sure that as we onboard those
people as we bring those people into the
web3 ecosystem that that community that
those people that we galvanize around
the palm network is as diverse as as
engaged as possible so that's how i see
my role as head of community
absolutely and when we at vayner talk
about web 3 and nfts and and brands
moving into this space we always lead
through the lens of community and how
community building is so important and
how community is the only way that any
brand or any project for that matter is
going to have any any success at all in
this space
and so in terms of that as we talk to
marketers on this program
how would you suggest that brands
engage or interact with these
communities as they're tiptoeing or
creeping or walking or running into the
space
yeah it's a really really great question
i think i think you know i think um
a four-prong approach right educate
because that that presents wonderful
opportunities um incentivize engage and
then focus on retention
for me
i think that web 3 presents really
wonderful opportunities for marketers to
think differently than they did in web 2
particularly when it comes to
incentivizing audiences i think and
communities i think that audiences and
communities in web 3 have learned from
web 2 and they understand the value that
they bring
and so this notion of a corporation or a
brand um building on the backs of the
community and them getting nothing is is
literally a thing of the past uh they
want to be incentivized and it's really
up to marketers i think to understand
the unique needs of their audience in
their community and to be able to
incentivize them uh accordingly um you
know
we've we who were in the space we've
heard of the air drops and the road maps
and all of that but i think those are
that's really where you're going to make
i think a big difference with your
community is how you incentivize them
absolutely
and along the lines of the topics of
incentivization and airdrops and some of
these more mechanical things you're also
a storyteller so in terms of web3 and
nfts what are some of the new stories
that brands are able to tell leveraging
this technology or ways that narrative
can be
part of the part of these activations
that brands are doing in this space
oh i think web 3 opens up a wonderful
world for for storytelling um i think
for brands in particular um there's
there's so much they can do i think it
really depends on on what your brand is
and how you lean into um i think there's
an opportunity to
really trace the history of a brand in a
wonderfully unique way in web 3. um i'm
seeing interesting things happening with
uh
specifically around storytelling with
film and and and web3
and know that we focus mostly on art and
now
music but i think that there are
interesting possibilities that that uh
narrative storytelling filmmaking uh
hold in the space as well um
i've featured
a filmmaker a few weeks ago who minted
her film on the blockchain and i think
that brands can certainly tap into those
opportunities as well yeah
double clicking there in terms of both
community engagement storytelling do you
have a short list of do's and don'ts for
brands engaging in web 3 and nfts maybe
things that you've seen work
particularly well things that you've
seen not go so well
i think that it's really important for
brands to think
long term we touched briefly on the idea
of a road map
and a road map is not just what happens
from now until the launch you have to
think well past the launch and really
think about how you're going to
continually
evolve the story of what you're doing i
think that that is the biggest thing i
don't even have like a do or don't i
think keeping that in mind i think the
idea of how you continually engage your
community is going to be critical you
loop your story into that and everything
else but if you drop the ball there
i think uh
not a good thing
absolutely
our time is almost up but i absolutely
wanted to hear about your your project
blockchain and what you're doing there
yeah you know so when i got into the
space i i i approached it from an
investor's lens right i had a thesis
about what i wanted to see and naturally
because of who i am and the work that
i've done um i i was looking for people
that looked like me um and i didn't
necessarily see uh
as much as that as i would have liked um
and so given my entrepreneurial
background uh i thought hey that there's
something that doesn't exist here and so
my natural inclination is to create what
i don't see um and so to that end um i
created the blockchain i started as a
weekly newsletter it has since then
evolved into a community of artists and
collectors uh we amplify the work of
women and by talking lgbtq artists and
collectors um in the nft space and so um
it's it's been thriving and growing uh
we now have the audacious goal of
creating the largest diverse digital art
collection anywhere so uh we're off to
the races yeah very impressive and
looking forward to seeing more from that
and what that project gives to the world
last question for you some of you are
apart from your own projects some of
your favorite web 3 or nft communities
projects things that you think are
interesting fascinating telling for
marketers out there yeah um i love what
the cool cats are doing um i think
barring some recent minor delays i
really love the way that they're rolling
that out i could comment on bake but i'm
not because i think everyone will
probably touch on that so i'll leave
that alone uh i love a lot of the
women-led projects that i'm seeing in
the space i love the intention around
inclusivity that i see around some of
the women projects the women-led
projects in the space
i think that we don't necessarily uh
some of those projects don't float to
the top as as much as they should but uh
women rise and and boss babes they're
doing fantastic work in the space um and
i think that they don't necessarily get
as much credit as as as they're do
absolutely i'm looking forward to seeing
how things like blockchain and some of
the other projects in the space can uh
can forward some of those projects and
put a spotlight on them
thanks so much sean thanks for having me
absolutely thank you sean
next up we welcome peg samuel co-founder
and head of entertainment at fierce
studios
peg is an innovation tech consultant nyu
professor advisor and author and she's
been in the digital space for more than
25 years
she specializes in communications and
connecting the dots for tech businesses
welcome peg
hello
how's it going peg it's uh wonderful to
have you on thank you good to see you
again yeah and i'm just grinning because
we have two incredibly multi-talented
women you are also a what i call a slash
professor slash author slash marketer
slash og in the web3 space
so i think the audience would love to
hear a little bit about you how you got
into the web3 space originally and maybe
some of the projects that you're working
on these days yeah thank you so much
yeah because i'm i'm currently head of
entertainment um and co-founder of fewer
studios and we'll get to that um but
exactly in 25 years you get a lot of
slashes
um so
quick the quick journey is i i i was
around for web one like i worked at
weather channel
before weather.com came out and i was
like i want to work on this what is this
this is amazing and then
just stayed in digital digital marketing
communications
um for my whole career so it's like web
web one then i had a social media agency
um and so web two and now
web
three yeah
interestingly enough we're playing with
this narrative within vaynermedia that
if web one was the rise of the digital
agency and web 2.0 was the rise of the
social agency does that mean that web 3
is the rise of the metaverse agency and
what might that be
in terms of
shifting consumer attention in terms of
technologies time spent culture new ways
of engaging with tech technology like
nfts and arvr
that resonates with you at all as
someone who's a native crypto
person but also a marketer yeah i mean
that absolutely i love this question
that's so smart and i appreciate it and
i would expect nothing less from vayner
you know this is so great so you know
the the one thing for web3 it's like
community and everybody touched upon
that i actually you know spent the time
listening to all the different speakers
leading up to me and it's been
incredible um and you've touched on it
like metaverse we've gotten into the
metaverse in my project and i really
thought we were you know in some ways in
some places it's too soon and in
metaverse i'm like okay these are you
know i have a co-founder she's amazing
she's visionary names michelle mccormick
and she was talking metaverse early on
and i thought okay you know we'll get
there but it has been like the super
speed of crypto and nfts to get there
now and
um been really fun and i agree that like
web 3 means community and that community
like rules and now
because of globally we've had you know
pandemic and then all the all that we're
all now more comfortable with tech and
connecting this way and and clubhouse
had come out that
like let's meet in the metaverse you
know
absolutely
so we touched briefly upon fear studios
can you tell us a little bit more about
what that project is absolutely i think
it's a great intersection of brands and
and web3 technology so i would love to
hear from the marketers out there how
brands are working with you at fear
studios yeah absolutely and again is
interesting it's like okay we have these
ideas we wanted to do this project but
where when you bring in other brands or
people it's like and even community it's
like where let's meet the let's meet the
market where it's at so it's fear
studios
where 10 000 generative pro you know pfp
project
and we
brought real models in so we have
diversity that was very important to us
and um the generative thing is it builds
community
and it's meeting the market where it's
at and at first we were able to do a
deal with saucy the global sneaker brand
and we drew in as a rarity trade these
sneakers and again
like we thought let's just do it as a
like a a little rarity trait versus you
know something really in your face
and so that's how we tied in with that
brand and then now that that's live we'd
like to like march some brands over to
the metaverse with wearables but in the
meantime we're just um simply connecting
them up and gifting our pfps based on
traits so it's like kind of like baby
steps into
into full-blown metaverse like d-gen
absolutely before we go further can you
explain to everybody what pfp stands for
and what that is what kind of project
that is very good point so pfp um i
think
it's the profile pic gosh for a second i
was thinking wait a minute what is it
what is it oh no um so profile pic so
what happened the phenomenon that
happened and this would be like my
professor hat is like as nfts went
really bullish over the pandemic people
started changing their twitter avatar to
flex their nft
uh their nfts as their profile pic and
now it's just like really fun and and
and also it's kind of funny because i i
was like okay this is what i actually
look like like not the avatar sometimes
so
yeah absolutely one of the things that
we talk about in terms of web3 for
brands and nft projects is that we see
web3 nfts as a continuation of human
behaviors that have
endured for thousands of years and and
one of those is the love to flex and
social and demonstrate social status and
so if you think about the floor price
for some of these projects uh board ape
for example
starts at 300 000 and so if you have a
board ape as your pfp that means that
either one you're incredibly wealthy and
able to afford uh having essentially a
jpeg
and represent you with that at that
price point or number two you were with
that community from them from the
beginning and gathered at an affordable
price and in either case there's a level
of social
status that that is
involved and and that's the the flexing
that's gone from
forever yeah
yeah media now to now to web 3. totally
that's why i think that's why i'm
getting even more and more bullish on
wearables because you know from a
reality standpoint right it's the same
thing like why is this worth so much
money and you know there's some stats
there and i've seen some brands that are
early on in gaming like like
i'm not sure if gucci is the right
example but it's like a gucci bag is
worth a gucci bag like it'll be just as
expensive but when i think about it and
i go i show up in one of the
metaverses
um you know you can dress up your avatar
and you
it's flexing right there too it's like
well what are they wearing like i want
to wear something like that so
it's it's the same thing it's going to
come over and it's but it can be like
fun and adventurous and
unique and so i'm really excited about
that yeah i am too
one of the things that i really like
about your projects there is that um the
nfts include utility and utility is one
of the things that we talk about as
being a great gateway for some of these
projects and so would love to talk about
at a high level how you see utility
playing a role in some of these projects
and the specific
utility that's built into some of your
partnerships and collaborations with
brands yeah for sure and i think some of
this stuff is like it's been said here
already like we're building the plane as
we're flying it right and it's like
where can we meet brands where they're
at or what do people want like like are
what does our community want but what
can we also offer so
um sometimes i and i know this is not
the definition of utility but sometimes
as like a tech person i'm thinking well
isn't there some coded
secret sauce like coded into these nfts
that then will unlock and
you know all of those things and
yes that is incredibly interesting to me
and i think i'm really bullish on the
tech right
and you know but on a simplified matter
for some brands just kind of reeling
them in it's like hey utility to me can
also mean gifting like hey we have an
example we did something with pro
flowers which is like an ftd and what we
simply did was around valentine's day we
gifted
you know some sorry avatars have many
traits for people that don't know traits
it's like generative projects just like
trade up with different things so one of
our traits is an afro with roses in the
hair
so
simply enough we said hey pro flowers
let's let's you know they want to work
with us let's gift um in like a giveaway
style um
our holders that have that trait and we
sent them irl two dozen roses
for
for valentine's day but taking it a step
further would be like really fun to then
say okay well can we bring those roses
over to the metaverse and gift the whole
collection and that becomes a gift slash
a utility slash tack
um could the nft unlock
you know roses at a later standpoint so
like some of those ideas i think could
be really cool and and fun for whoever's
game for it absolutely and it's it's
almost as though these
these cases of utility give brands the
opportunity to do things in terms of
providing benefits whether that's
digital goods gary has a has a nnft
under his v friends collection called
the gift goat yeah where holders receive
three or four gifts per year and that
might be an nft but it also might be
something physical and similarly brands
can do interesting things whether
holding that token
unlocks another nft or some sort of
token gated experience but it could also
be discounts for physical goods it could
also be
a loyalty program type special
benefits so there there really is a
fascinating world here to to unlock
i agree because i think with brands it's
like okay what are all the things that
you've been doing this is back to web
one or two right like all the promotions
but how can you authentically bring it
into the metaverse so it's like last
thing we want to do is like shoot out a
bunch of discount
code as an nft right or something it's
like how do you mindfully bring it in so
the community is like really stoked
about it and so they're just you know
they're all things to be worked on and
it's all innovation to be had some some
you know some things you think could be
interesting and then you see it flop or
vice versa you know so it's like
it's really fun and honestly like i
almost was gonna say it because i hear
it all the time like it's the wild wild
west right and but for me if it's called
that i'm literally in the middle of the
right place because it's always so much
fun yeah absolutely last question for
you we had sean we have you two
incredible women in the web 3mt space
we'd love to hear if you have any
favorite women-led projects in the
webinar or nft world that you'd like to
shout out yeah for sure
except for our own right fears um i love
i've i've loved been
been following world of women and
everything they're up to i mean they
have checked so many boxes since the
beginning that's been amazing um fame
ladies like the takeover incredible you
know um longer story probably but people
could look that up and the other one
that i've been really
bullish interesting is wow pixies they
are derivative but they're going to do
their own art and then there's a dao
interesting
i'd like to give a special shout out to
flower girls which is one of my
favorites yes
yes they're beautiful too they are
yeah there's so many they're arts and
that's a it's a wonderful thing that the
the group of women-led projects seems to
be
expanding day by day yeah um in any case
it's been wonderful to have you peg
thanks so much
thank you peg i just did want to mention
that for those that want to hit peg up
her twitter handle her additional
twitter handle is at fear studio nft
thank you so much eric for leading all
of those conversations
thank you
we'll see you soon
all right well last but certainly not
least we have the congressman
tom emmer join who joined avery echonini
earlier this week in a pre-recorded
conversation
um we're going to be sharing it with you
now on just a little bit of a background
on tom he is currently serving his
fourth term in congress and sits on the
house financial services committee he
grew up in minnesota and served in the
minnesota house of reps from 2004 to
2008. listen into the conversation now
you don't want to miss this one
good morning and hello everyone welcome
to marketing for the now i'm adriani
president of vayner nft and i'm so
fortunate to be joined by tom emmer tom
thank you so much for making the time to
be here with us on the show
glad to be with you avery
awesome tom we'd love to learn a little
bit more about you would you please
introduce yourselves to our audience
well
my name is tom emmer i represent one of
the eight congressional districts house
districts in the state of minnesota it's
called
the sixth district of
minnesota
i i've been in the u.s house of
representatives now i think this is my
fourth term that we're a little bit more
than halfway through
i sit on the house financial services
committee on the they call it the
ranking member because we're in the
minority the ranking member on the house
oversight committee uh
obviously uh i'm a
co-chair of the blockchain caucus and
have been now for a while because of
some things i hope we're going to talk
about this morning
because it's a big interest of mine uh
and uh look i i have uh as i was talking
about with one of your colleagues
earlier i have uh my wife and i have
seven kids uh ages uh 31 down to almost
21
uh and it keeps you young it keeps you
young it keeps you looking at things
that uh they're doing
uh in a world that is fast changing and
uh you know what avery uh all you and
your peers uh are gonna be looking at a
completely different uh social fabric
than what we have had growing up
uh and that's uh that's who i am that's
where i come from that's why i'm so
interested in what we're going to talk
about
fantastic and and tom you've um
beyond just sort of your role uh in sort
of leading the blockchain caucus you've
actually introduced legislation to
provide clarity for blockchain
innovators can you share a little bit
more about this legislation and what it
means to to normal folks
right i actually have introduced
three bills that provide regulatory
clarity for tax law securities law and
money transmission laws
and i've introduced one bill that
focuses on leading digital currency
innovation that would be open
permissionless and private right same
attributes as cash avery
but the first one the securities clarity
act would allow the sec
and token issuers to easily determine
when a token is offered as part of a
securities contract i mean some of your
uh
your audience probably is well aware of
the
lack of leadership we've seen out of
gary gensler at the sec
he seems to be in
conducting regulation through
enforcement actions and public
statements
this would allow which by the way
creates all kinds of uncertainty uh this
would allow entrepreneurs innovators
some certainty in the marketplace so
they know if they have to comply with
securities laws as opposed to
what we have now in my opinion which is
a full employment opportunity for
lawyers who are trying to interpret uh
this howie test that existed long before
uh
you know the satoshi white paper
uh the next one is the blockchain
regulatory certainty act uh this would
assert that blockchain entities that
never custody consumer funds are never
considered considered money transmitters
then we have the safe harbor for
taxpayers with fort assets act which
would protect taxpayers from a tax
obligation that they did not seek out
and might not even know they have as you
know i if
a blockchain forks
you and i may not have anything to do
with that decision but right now it
could have some uh
tax consequences that again i don't
think we should be responsible for uh if
we didn't actually create that for
uh and then recently we offered the
central bank digital currency bill
this is one that's close to my heart
because i've got some serious heartburn
when our government says they're going
to create a cbdc and they're going to
follow china's lead our bill would
prohibit the u.s government from
developing a surveillance tool that
would strip away financial freedom and i
believe deflate the dollar's dominance
so those are the bills right now that
we've been pushing uh and frankly we've
got some great response tom you must
have uh you must have had a lot of
thoughts when the new executive order
came out yesterday
i think the executive order uh
it's uh you know you might uh take a
look at our twitter
uh
stream twitter uh uh oh non twitter feed
yes yeah thank you the twitter feed you
might take a look at that because uh
it's very interesting
uh we did point out that we've had a
chance to go through that uh here in the
office
let's just say the good news is uh
they're directing the bureaucracies to
start to study this
let's be realistic
good for you
mr president good for you biden
administration but in fact they've been
studying it for quite some time now
the question is if you're going to
recognize the talent that is within
these bureaucracies
that is forward thinking that is
actually looking at this as an
opportunity as opposed to a danger it
seems to me like the people at the top
of the pyramid in this government are
scared to death of crypto they're scared
to death of by losing their ability to
be the the ultimate intermediary in our
financial transactions and so they're
trying how to uh you know they tried to
kill it in my opinion uh initially they
couldn't do that because this is gonna
happen with or without us i believe
and now they're trying to figure out how
to absorb it into themselves that's
where cbdc scares the living daylights
out of someone like me
but
i digress so they put it out they said
they're going to study it great
we were laughing this morning uh about
the fact that
gary gensler wasn't asked for anything
yeah that's probably the best thing
that's in the executive order is they
didn't ask him for any input since he's
been giving awful output for the last uh
uh several well i would suggest months
uh but listen
if we're going to take i i'm a glass
half full skies blue kind of person so
if we just get rid of the cynicism uh
and perhaps some of my skepticism
uh the fact that they're actually
acknowledging it and that they're going
to uh you know have some discussion
about it internally that we hope will
lead to some external uh leadership i
think that's a good thing but uh
let's just say it's not all-encompassing
uh these guys i have a long way to go
before they understand what stable coins
really are or what they might mean and
the list is much longer than that they
just hear crypto and
some of them just go
yeah well it's uh i like the way that
you called it regulatory clarity which i
think is really what a lot of consumers
and crypto users are seeking so tom
you're clearly incredibly well versed in
this stuff what inspired you to jump
head first into the world of blockchain
and crypto was it seeing your kids sort
of in this ecosystem or you know seeing
your constituents
i it really starts with my own family
right uh
i i was one of these uh uh my wife and i
were parents that you got to get out
right i want you on the hockey rink i
want you out uh in the woods
i i want you fishing i want you doing
stuff that's outside and you probably
have heard this from your own family
avery you know what are you doing on
that computer get outside do whatever
happens yes right well it's uh it really
stems from all of them but i would tell
you probably the most influential was
our baby who's now a uh sophomore in
college you know he uh he started
working at age 15
as young people get
money right they start to earn their own
income
uh they don't need their parents telling
them what to do with it right so uh he
literally built his own computer
i got me to start thinking yeah i would
never do stuff like this in fact i
probably was more afraid in the
beginning that this kid is about to
start mining his own bitcoin out of my
house and what does that mean but what
does that mean for energy bills right
well but talking to him too by the way
uh every it's i i've i have learned that
the younger generation
does not see things the way mine does my
generation grew up with a book in their
hand my generation grew up with
newspapers on the kitchen table my
generation grew up with a radio in the
car that i pushed the buttons and the
biggest innovation in the 1970s moving
into the 80s was oh we've got fm what is
this fm thing that's cool
well that's not the world we live in
today and so
you're talking to somebody who sees
things more in two-dimension
right
you start talking about those uh
innovators today those uh entrepreneurs
my kids uh and their peers
they see in 3d they see
beyond 3d they they have an ability to
do abstract thinking uh in in vision you
know forward-looking vision that
we don't have so i became in
then i have a uh another child uh he's
not a child he's a full-grown adult
that's uh making a good living
who got involved in in trading
cryptocurrencies right
i personally have tried to stay away
because if i do uh start trading
people here are going to say look
emmer's all into this industry because
he's invested now
no my wife would like me to be but uh i
think right now if we're going to be an
advocate for the uh
entrepreneurs out there for this uh
space in our financial system for this
evolution i think it's better that we uh
we don't have that criticism so
i
these guys got me to look at things that
perhaps i never would have and think in
ways that i never would have so
i i actually evolved because uh probably
the entire
my entire life
i've been very suspicious of government
and uh what this cryptocurrency exposure
has done
is it's expanded me to start looking at
the real thing for me which
cryptocurrency is facilitating
is the evolution of web 2 which is all
intermediaries based
to web 3 where you and i
we
will have our own digital identities and
we can do business directly with each
other we don't need an intermediary you
know it's it's that uh
example that i've given before about uh
youtube you know you're aspiring a young
entertainer whether you're a singer a
comedian who knows all the comedians
they're not allowed to be funny about
much anymore but let's just say you're a
uh
an aspiring entertainer
today you're putting your content out
there perhaps on youtube
well great somebody else controls that
platform and the only way you can derive
value for the value you're providing is
if you sell advertising directly to that
uh youtube site i think of a world avery
where i don't need youtube anymore
i can create an nft i can put it out
there and people can literally give me
value if they see value in what i've
offered in that
non-fungible token so and this will
evolve more but to me that's the big
issue is the evolution from web 2 to web
3 i don't need big tech i don't need big
government i don't need big whatever
keeping their eye on me and controlling
my data which i by the way it's
interesting to me we may not uh be
pleased at times with certain
politicians but it's interesting that uh
the intermediaries in this country
exclude certain political views
but there's a guy in the kremlin who
apparently can still
uh gain access that's right that's
that's why it's so important for you and
me to be able to make our own decisions
and i'm not saying intermediaries will
uh be totally gone but avery and tom
should be able to decide when we want to
use an intermediary and when we just
want to uh do business uh directly
absolutely tom thank you so much for
joining us on the show today i know
you're joining us at vcon which is gary
vaynerchuk's first ever conference for
the friends token holders so we're so
excited to see what vcon thank you so
much for taking the time to chat with us
sharing your viewpoints um incredibly
interesting and we're really grateful to
you for for being with us here today but
thank you avery look forward to seeing
you in minneapolis
thanks
thanks everybody for hanging on to see
catch that last one please join us for
our next episode of marketing for the
now on april 14th from 12 to 1 pm
eastern time where we will talk about
what are your hot takes for 2022 we have
a great list of authors and business
leaders and uh industry icons that are
going to be joining us for that one
please hit us up let us know what you
thought about this episode and we hope
to see you very very soon